what's the deal man it's your boy kaelin
for real from checking me out on the
bootleg keg podcast
my bad bro what's the deal man it's your
boy caleb for real for one check me out
on the bootleg kev
almost didn't say pocket
what's the deal man it's your boy
katelyn for real for and checking me out
on the bootleg keg
what's that that's hard to say bootleg
cap no like all the podcast bootleg kev
podcast all right there it is there it
is what's the deal man it's your boy
kevin for real for and check me out on
the bootleg
what's the deal with this your boy
caitlyn for real for real and checking
me out on the bootleg calf podcast right
now y'all should keep every take oh yeah
that's all going in
who like cap show special guest in here
the new album is out friday friday so
what is that like two days from now
three days
tomorrow well thursday night thursday
night we're gonna say three days though
caitlyn for real for real is here ladies
and gentlemen two for it two for real
for real pharrell i don't know what the
[ __ ] i've been saying it both ways
forever no what's the official
calendar for real too for real right
they know
is there a way that someone shouldn't
say it don't say colon
don't say kalin what if they say kaylynn
frfr uh i'll take that i'm gonna say for
real for real
so they know that it's for real has
anyone ever done that like you've ever
gone into an interview for rfr i'm like
you know what i mean for real free i
thought it meant for real for real
that's all you didn't
yeah
can you imagine going into an interview
they don't even know what the [ __ ] i've
done interviews and people didn't know
who they were they didn't know my name
or anything about me where was this at
i'm not gonna do that the radio room at
bt or something no it never where was it
this is just what's in life la this was
in l.a i've just done interviews places
and they didn't know who i was well
you've been on like promo runs yeah yeah
i've done a lot so if you get into a
situation where someone doesn't know who
you are how do you keep it professional
you just start talking about yourself
like you just gotta do your part like
you gotta take over that yo i'm killing
for real for real from la you know what
i'm saying
you know my album out right now
you're a pro i try
you're a pro that's right hey you know i
think something that you did that was
like super important that and
you guys shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
anyway
i think i was going to say that's
president ray
reza and ray just no respect rez and ray
with the zero respect
[Laughter]
um
i feel like you know
we've seen so many la artists
hit it like hit the la ceiling quick or
the west coast ceiling quick but i feel
like you kind of did
uh
something that a lot of people should
kind of take note of and that's you kind
of started to
like a few years ago you really tapped
in with atlanta you were staying out
there you was moving around in florida
you was kind of like really like making
sure that like you
got your [ __ ] going
everywhere as opposed to just focusing
on la and i feel like it's benefited you
yeah definitely i didn't ever want to
just
be famous here right you know
i like i i feel like it don't kind of
let you famous everywhere like you know
what i'm saying unless you can go all
over like or i ain't gonna say it don't
count it's just my dreams and my
expectations of where i want to be is
just
not just l.a you know what i'm saying so
it's like you know the best thing to do
is to go
be around those people you know what i'm
saying like
the way
it was
transparent like the way my music like
it didn't really start at least started
in san diego because i was in san diego
you know what i'm saying so when i was
spending time in and when i came back
home in l.a i'd
keep pushing my music out letting people
know i make music meeting people you
know what i'm saying in atlanta same
thing in florida same thing in minnesota
the same thing just moving around
different places and having homies in
different places that's you feel me
liking my music and it just kept
transpiring until i got it's like just
gradually growing you know what i'm
saying were people confusing that you
were from san diego for a while people
think i'm from everywhere i hear all
kinds of [ __ ] people think i'm from um
people think i'm from
i'm from la people would be like he from
he from san diego people he from atlanta
um
i heard i was from the bay
really yeah
i got i was from minnesota
um
what's up with the minnesota [ __ ]
oh that's random nah like because i'm a
muslim and i have like a gang of somali
and homies like my best friend somalia
okay okay so like yeah i know there's a
huge somalian population in minnesota
like in minnesota minneapolis i started
like i did my first show at for real
that's a great uh a great market
people don't talk about minneapolis
enough it's i've been there it's a good
good city beautiful beautiful place and
there's beautiful people out there for
sure
and it's like
so much out there so many people there
that you know i mean like no it's a
movie out there it's a great they got so
many dope music venues too yeah it's
like uh they got they got their own
music out there and stuff too it's not
like they own like you know
not
what up we got to stop the interview
real quick um to tell you about our good
folks at blue chew don't forget man
right now you get a whole month of blue
chew
for free that's right fellas you're
dealing with that erectile dysfunction
maybe you're under some stress some
anxiety maybe your man ain't working the
way it's supposed to
listen blue chew got you same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis
uh but it goes straight to your doorstep
in discrete packaging uh no doctor's
appointments where you got to go show up
to the doctor's office and have some
awkward conversation about why you're
[ __ ] ain't up the bar bud no sir all
online go to bluechew.com use the promo
code bootleg that's bluechu.com
promo code
bootleg use the promo code for me it
helps us out all right go do that and
tell me how your dick is i'll take dm
just don't send me a picture of it
because that will get you blocked bud
it's like they have their own pocket
they got music well they got a crazy
scene out there yeah yeah like lizzo
popped off out there that's crazy how
you know that yeah she was staying out
there her dj's from out there i i think
originally she's from texas but she
really started like popping that's crazy
i had a lot of family in minnesota too
that's crazy like my father my
grandfather's side of my family shout
out to the soda man yes how long have
you gone
i've been muslim for four years now
how does how does that happen like i'm
just you know just being around my
homies they was practicing and um i just
i was into the faith you know i'm saying
i was in the islam and just studying up
on it before i did it my homie passed
away i was like i'm like i'm gonna
convert to islam like when i get older
you know i'm saying like when i'm a
older man i'm living better like you
know my homie passed away and one of my
other homies i was talking about telling
a story the other day my other homies uh
gucci he was just like man you know why
wait
you know you never know right when your
last day is so literally um it was
during ramadan when ramadan ended that
eid uh converted
so do you like pray every day
um i'm not the best muslim but i'm
trying you're trying you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah but no
i don't pray every day i should though
definitely should because aren't you
supposed to pray five times a day uh-huh
so sometimes you go you put the donut on
the board on the prayer for a scoreboard
um i thank god every day okay yeah do
you have a rug yeah i have a prayer mess
everything you take that with you on the
road yeah that's important oh absolutely
what was it about the muslim faith that
like uh appealed to you
it was really like so much
the
the way they carry themselves you know
what i'm saying the way we carry
ourselves from um the way the reasons
that we celebrate ramadan you know the
reasons that we fast the reasons um
that you don't put the toxins and stuff
into your body you know what i'm saying
i'm not saying i don't sin i'm not
saying that i don't have a good time no
swine huh no never never no were you
were you eating swine before being
muslim yeah but i had stopped because
like i'm around all my homies all the
time they don't eat it like it's like
bro i'm not gonna just be the only one
eating pork
do you miss bacon no
not really never
like you ever walk and make me sick you
ever walk out of a club and then you
smell like the little ladies making the
hot dogs yeah that's it make my stomach
hurt really yeah i don't eat beef either
though you don't eat red meat i don't
eat no red meat at all what's wrong with
you man nah man i just i feel better i
promise you and i smoke a lot of weed so
like that'll be bad too
you smoke a lot of weed yeah
and don't eat red meat i understand the
swine religious reasons yeah but the red
meat though is because it's just like a
health thing like when you smoke a lot
of weed like that's why [ __ ] be
looking sick like you gotta eat
vegetables you gotta eat good like you
gotta drink water let me get this right
dr kalin is here yeah that's actually
the doctor that uh delivered me his name
is dr kayla i better yes swear to god
really yeah is that why your name is
arnold kalin yeah oh so that's your name
or your name after the guy who delivered
you yeah yeah my mom wasn't supposed to
be able to he must have a hell of a job
yeah now my mom wasn't supposed to have
no kid are you only child yeah i'm the
only kid yeah i'm the only one i made it
so if you smoke a [ __ ] in a world
especially i was the sperm that made it
you smoke a lot of weed right yeah you
should not eat red meat um that's not
like that's not a fact
but i just want to see if we're getting
getting into
in the chakra uh doctor type vibes
but it's like you know red meat will
slow you down right if like if you stop
eating red meat for like a week or two
weeks all right and you won't go back to
it
for a little while promise
i don't know if i can
you won't
you'll feel better how often do you eat
a burger
once a week so imagine if you but i'm on
keto so i'll eat the burger by itself
no button
that's like a waste of burger no it's
not i'll go to mcdonald's and get a
double cheeseburger with no meat
what is that it's like a fancy grilled
cheese sandwich you said a double
cheeseburger with no meat cheeseburgers
going on there it's like a fancy grilled
cheese sandwich
you'll do that like right now i did i
like i did that probably like last week
just like just bread mustard ketchup
pickles you know what i'm saying onions
it's like a fancy ass grilled cheese
sandwich
yeah you're a sick man man it's like the
same thing you're gonna go get a grilled
cheese sandwich with thousand island and
onions and all that from
from uh in and out i just wanna march
for mcdonald's this was a vegetarian and
he's [ __ ] he's loving this [ __ ]
because i bust his balls all the [ __ ]
time my producer
he's like yes you tell him you [ __ ]
sell them bro we go to mcdonald's and we
get double cheeseburgers no meat yeah
hell yeah
the only place i think that's acceptable
that is in and out because they do a
grilled cheese that's [ __ ] they do a
good girl
that's all it is is two pieces of bread
slapped together with some cheese in the
middle i go to in and out and you get a
flying dutchman i don't know what that
is just a piece of meat deep fried with
mustard on each side or you get the
tomato bun
yeah but you're not helping yourself i
feel good i've lost 25 pounds
i feel [ __ ] great i'm telling you if
you stop eating red meat do you smoke a
lot of wheat no i mean you don't have to
like the wage it like that like i
literally smoke an excessive amount of
wheat i just eat a lot of shroomies i
take shrooms too but you got to be
healthy for all of these things
yeah yeah man i can't be like right you
probably smoke a lot more weed i
probably smoke
five days out of the month how many
times did you smoke today zero yeah so
you're not as high as no no it depends
like i have to be in a situation where
i'm like
already partying
or i'm djing and there's weed getting
past or i have to smoke to smoke
yeah you're a real fight
no not you think you're a drug addict
um it's a weed a drug yeah i don't think
so but you know phenomenal somebody
enjoy
texas does i don't think i'm a drug
addict and i'm not worried about anybody
in texas do you think you're dependent
on thc
are you thc dependent i think drugs like
me
if it's a drug but since what's the
craziest drug you've done just weed and
mushrooms yeah shrooms but those are
like i've never done like ecstasy or
anything no that's not me i've done
ecstasy on accident whoa yeah it was an
accident man how the [ __ ] that
happened by the way gotta be a crazy
night right funny story so
partying with a lot of you guys favorite
rappers and um
drop a name no
just say
i'm sure he doesn't mind you sharing
this story because he's talking about
all the drugs he does on the podcast
[ __ ]
somebody i bring a [ __ ] bottle of
champagne for [ __ ] chike's birthday i
bring a bottle of champagne
somebody else bring the same bottle with
champagne but you know what i'm saying
was it bel air they're vibing
and did you bring bel air
we were this is a long time ago so was
it bellaire it was a long time ago but
it was around a long time ago it was i
wasn't old enough to drink alcohol a
long time ago so we were talking about
apple cider continue
it was bel air
[Laughter]
oh
it was better so jose you know what i'm
saying i drunk the wrong uh i grabbed
the bottle like [ __ ] drink the whole
bar are they spiking champagne with that
like the champagne gang so um damn this
this can't come out this is like me
telling the police like i'm not [ __ ]
with this listen i'd like to point out
that ruchi went into detail his extreme
ecstasy use and how he jerked off on
ecstasy before on this podcast he don't
give a [ __ ] okay okay literally on the
internet right right now all right
ruchi bought a [ __ ] four foot bong to
the interview all right yeah all right
that's my brother i just would never no
no no no no no
i promise you we can facetime him right
now
he doesn't care
ruchi is no shame about his ecstasy use
i promise you that
he my man is outside
he got me one to try this is a prop
conversation all this conversation is
for props to pure entertainment
hey we're i'm on an interview right now
wake up [ __ ]
what's up yeah look i'm a bullet kid hey
this guy's hey hey this guy's trying to
tell the story about he had when you
spiked me fool when you drugged me
oh
i think he's worried that you care that
people know you do ecstasy and i was
like well we've talked about it in
detail on the podcast like a month ago
you two turned gang right now
hey oh my god
youtube okay so you you drink the spiked
champagne yeah how was the rest of the
night
it was crazy i had it on it was a pool
party you know i had on grace sweats
did you have a [ __ ]
your dick print was it was crazy fool so
i was it was
does that mean you were [ __ ] you your
man was uh standing attention i was so
it was crazy it was embarrassing you
were rocked up i was rocked up and i was
vibed out they said i was coolest [ __ ]
in a party of course they did yeah
you're the only person with great
sweatshirt this is me though
i can just picture you [ __ ] with no
shirt on great sweats just graceless no
shoes
yeah man and
it was a great night did you hook up
that night i don't remember yeah yeah i
don't think i did though i heard that
like uh ecstasy is like fun
on drugs i wouldn't know because i've
never done it yeah i'm afraid to do any
i'm not a drugger you're either drunk
do the weed and the shrooms and the
alcohol the i stay away from the alcohol
but the weed and um the shrimp is
amazing yeah i feel like especially
nowadays you know i don't give a [ __ ]
how plugged you are you might be [ __ ]
eating some [ __ ] fentanyl boys you
know yeah you don't know what you're
getting nowadays yeah yeah i'll try this
that fatty one man the drugs are
dangerous right now you don't do drugs
they're terrible or you know [ __ ] um
skid row
they don't even want the press [ __ ] they
just want the fentanyl
i don't know man i haven't been over
there you've been over there
yeah it's i mean i've walked through
downtown and walked through clouds of
crack smoke recently for sure yeah it's
like dodging human feces and cracks
maybe [ __ ] on the ground over there
like literally on the ground we gotta do
something about that man
yeah maybe like a a universal porta
potty but you know i was serious though
like where do you want to go i'm saying
like if download pass out sandwiches and
[ __ ] you know you'll go with me yeah
sure all right i'm gonna hold you to
that my mom does that like once a year
my mom's a good person i'll do it once a
year as long as it's once a year i can't
commit to much more than that
we're gonna go and make sure you're over
there
hey we gotta hold him to that
no i thought you were talking about we
got to do something about the [ __ ] on
the ground oh no i'm not going to touch
any [ __ ] we need to do a porta potty
like on every other coin i'm that
neighbor
when your dog shits
you know but they don't clean it up
you're uh
you're not [ __ ] around no
have you ever had a neighbor's dog [ __ ]
in your yard um yeah
did you clean it or did you put it back
in their yard you just threw it over
yeah respect that yeah yeah
yeah it's very a bad etiquette if you
own an animal you walk the dog you have
little [ __ ] bags i don't be having
sometimes you forget to grab the little
[ __ ] bags so you've walked your dog and
it's pooped and you've left it
you're a bad citizen i see sorry are you
the police maybe
hey hey depending on which [ __ ]
youtube comments you read maybe i am
jesus christ i'm sure the [ __ ] ain't no
dj vlad that's for sure anyway
um yo so tell me the uh
the title to the project title project
is two two two man why two two two two
two two because two for real one two for
real two and this is technically two for
row three and also two two two being an
angel number i feel like that's my angel
number i see it a lot and it means
you're going in the right direction and
i feel like you know
from where i started to where i am now
and no telling where it can go with sky
being the limit i feel like we're going
in the right direction
what is an angel number i've never heard
of this oh so it's like if you see these
numbers like certain numbers like repeat
it they're considered angel numbers like
if it comes up in your life often
yeah like two two two one one one four
four four eleven eleven make a wish you
know
stuff like that so two two two to your
angel number yeah well obviously you and
uh blast bringing it back full circle on
the new single oh yeah no stopping
that's my boy man who don't know he did
uh get uh he produced right with it yeah
he did get uh get get right with it
right with it right now yeah
i for always forget that um
g parikho is on the original version of
that song why why you forget that
because i always play the remix oh yeah
with yg yeah you gotta play the original
shout out to perico
i hope he catches away because he's he's
also one of those like underappreciated
like la guys i feel like yeah he feels
like super talented
yeah no i know he feels like that yeah
um who else is on the project um nobody
just blast just blast and you and me i
like that it's a lot of different means
on there you know what i'm saying
different vibes different vibes
do you feel like uh because you're
pretty i do feel like you're pretty
versatile in the type of records you can
make and obviously just like with what
you do and
um
sound wise sonic wise do you feel like
you're like taking any risks on this
project that like maybe you haven't done
in the past yeah i feel like i'll take a
risk every time i put something out you
know what i'm saying
so so many people would be making like
the same
music right you know what i'm saying
and this is like
why if you can you know like i know
people are so much more talented than
what they express i want to express
everything you know i'm saying i don't
want to be put in a box
you know what i mean do you feel like at
any point in time like you felt like
people were putting you in a box no all
the time
like all the time i feel like oh yeah
he's a rapper he's a singer he's this
he's like it's just
i want you to like everything
you know what i'm saying i just want to
be an artist
i'm an artist yeah i agree i mean like i
got all different type of vibes and i'm
not gonna give you no song so
far-fetched to where you feel like oh
he's trying to be like somebody else
like no all of the stuff that i'm doing
is me so he's like it's very true to
yourself yeah definitely you got great
love songs you got turn up records yeah
and it's like why do i have to be
confined to one yeah when you do like a
love record like uh never lose you
obviously is a record that people love
uh
what are the what are those
real life situations you're writing like
to grab motivation from or
no like i'll be really going through
that [ __ ]
yeah
i'm really going through that [ __ ] are
you currently in a in a entanglement are
you single what's going on no i got
something going on you got something
going on yeah i got something's going on
when you have something going on and
you're killing right yeah and shit's
moving for you obviously you're doing
shows
is there like a
certain conversation because i feel like
if you're an artist and you're in a
relationship there has to be like a
mutual understanding of like hey look
like
i'm gonna get crazy dms
there's gonna be fans that show up to my
shows
but like you gotta kind of be in a
situation where that other person
understands that that just kind of comes
with what you do right yeah i mean
they gonna say they understand
but then they don't because you're gonna
get tripped on for sure but it's just
all a part of it like yo like who you
are as the person you know what i'm
saying as the person that's the artist
like it's a part of like who you are how
you handle yourself
like you know what i'm saying and it
just got to be fair like are you going
to be tripping if that's what be
happening you know what i'm saying
so if you can't like be fair then you
know you should maybe that's not the
right situation for you that's fair um i
feel like at a
a lot of the your peers um
you seem to really have like a nice
like grasp on your you like being
self-aware yeah having a good head on
your shoulders um moving with a lot of
intention
what what are some of the things that
like you've kind of applied
to your personal life to just this whole
[ __ ] because a lot of people can get
wrapped up in
um the lifestyle of being a popping
artist or you just gotta they can get
overwhelmed you know what i mean you
gotta be able to go to sleep at night
you know what i'm saying
like every day i could go get a good
night rest because i'm not hoeing nobody
i'm not out here faking no [ __ ] i'm not
worried about nobody looking for me
because i didn't lie or said i didn't
did something to any you know what i'm
saying i'm not in no fake beefs
i'm not you know what i'm saying i ain't
doing nothing to nobody i'm not trying
to harm nobody i just be straight up
like 100 like you know what i'm saying
you're going to get out what you put in
so if you're being a stand-up [ __ ] 100
of the time it's like
it's not fake i'm just being myself like
i'm it's it's harder to snake a [ __ ]
than to just be stand up i'd rather tell
me like hey bro i can't [ __ ] with you
like that yeah i don't even really see
you like you're really like not ever
mixed up enough of like [ __ ] [ __ ]
online or nothing yeah cause i said
[ __ ] like one it's like i look at it
you know what i'm saying two ways
like one it's not no point to be beefing
with nobody if you're not gonna kill him
straight up
so
we're not gonna just be going back and
forth shooting at each other or doing
[ __ ] like that because that's beef i
don't know it just arguing and [ __ ]
that's not beef right you know what i'm
saying and then it's like
another example of it is like why
yeah like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] am
i mad at you for like you know what i'm
saying like [ __ ] get into it over
females
that's what big island that's the number
one that's usually the number one thing
right it's usually or money and yeah
you know what i'm saying or you i can't
get into it with no [ __ ] being jealous
because i'm not jealous of no need you
shouldn't be yeah we gotta both be
jealous you know what i'm saying like
[ __ ] can't hate on me 100 like
all right bro like you know what i'm
saying you're gonna love me eventually
or you love me before
and if you don't who gives a [ __ ] yeah
at the end of the day
does it you know it doesn't stop nothing
i have going on you know what i'm saying
and if if a [ __ ] hated on me and it's
blocking something i got going on that's
all new
that's they got to live with that they
got to go to sleep with that all night
like damn i could've
this could be going on right now but i
did some hoe [ __ ] and now it's not going
on no more right now i gotta sleep with
that every day that's that's [ __ ] i
think it's great that you have that
figured out so young in life yeah cause
i feel like i didn't figure that [ __ ]
out i was like 30. that's my pop star
like i grew up on like prison politics
right yeah
so
it was like i had to get
acclimated to understanding like [ __ ]
you got to be a man all the time like
you know what i'm saying you got to
stand on business all the time and my
mom's too my mom's going to play that
[ __ ] my mom's really like
coming at me like i was a grown-ass man
since i was a little kid
you know what i'm saying like she treat
me like a grown man hey we gotta stop
the interview real quick tell you about
our good folks at odd socks uh listen go
to oddsoxofficial.com they're presenting
sponsor of the bootleg kit podcast when
you go on there use the promo code
bootleg cab all one word together
bootleg kev
and you're gonna get 20 off your entire
odd socks order they got all the crazy
licenses my g they got the basics they
got the twizzlers the warhead underwear
how about these these are godfather
draws you know i'm saying shout out to
the bootleg kev socks
we're gonna be dropping some merch
and if you buy the merch you get free
socks that's coming shortly uh but yo
oddssoxoficial.com
the most comfortable socks in the world
the craziest licenses they got some big
ones coming down the pipeline i can't
talk about but they just did drop
doritos and uh
[ __ ] cheetos and all that good [ __ ]
uh so listen go to oddssoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg cap save 20
off today go do that let's get back to
the interview like you know what i'm
saying when you were growing up were you
able to watch whatever you wanted
um to extent
like i know some people like when i was
a kid some of my friends weren't allowed
to watch the simpsons yeah but like i
grew up with a bunch of other kids and
like all my cousins and stuff like that
so i was like my mom worked a lot so
yeah i was doing whatever yeah like i
was i was grown you know what i'm saying
my mom left me at home by myself i was
like she figured he'd be all right i'll
be all right but it was cool cause she
knew like i wasn't gonna do nothing
stupid too stupid but i was gonna do
something stupid but not nothing crazy
like you know what i'm saying i was
gonna be able to feed myself all kind of
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying and my mom
was like cps so she was so scared
for like
[ __ ] that happens to other kids to
happen to me oh she worked for child
protective services
because she would be able to see she see
that the lows are the lows yeah like you
know what i'm saying like that [ __ ] real
depressing i can't imagine hell yeah
like she did that [ __ ] for twenty she
she's 27 years in she's been doing this
since i was waiting she's still doing it
yeah [ __ ] is day right now that's like a
uh that's got to be a tough job she
won't quit because some of the [ __ ] you
see gotta be crazy she won't quit
she won't quit
but that [ __ ] like that [ __ ] is crazy
you know literally there's no other word
for it it's crazy it's literally crazy
and um
[ __ ] like she just won't she don't never
want me to have to she used to try so
hard to keep me from
going in the direction of being able to
get faced with any of those things like
you know what i'm saying and then my mom
was sick a lot my mom had cancer and
[ __ ] when i was growing up so she kicked
the cancer yeah shout out to her man
shout out moms you know what i'm saying
hell yeah she's been fighting so my mom
didn't really work until like
because she couldn't like i remember
like a whole period of my mom not being
able to go to work because she literally
was like in and out of the hospital
every week like you know what i'm saying
like i'll remember this vividly like i'm
i'm a full like grown
like teenager
like i'm fully aware of what's going on
my mom's used to keeping g with me like
man like
[ __ ] you gotta be able to do this cause
i might not be here straight up
like
why you tell me that like but at the
same time it's like you know what i'm
saying that [ __ ] made me like all right
[ __ ] you have to do something right you
know what i'm saying like even if you're
doing something you still got to be
doing something and that's why i always
like
always kept to fight that balance like
i've been wanting to rap but i knew like
playing football and stuff like that
that could change my life too so like
wow you went to college yeah like
football paid for college right yeah no
i did what i had to yeah you know what
i'm saying like that's all like when
when them little kids in the park
playing football and [ __ ] like that
mm-hmm
ten of them kids like or like like three
four five of them kids on each team you
know what i'm saying some of them kids
is there to play football because they
fun but some of them kids really they're
like five six years old like me i'm
gonna save my mama
yeah i don't i don't doubt that like you
know what i mean so it's like
that was the mentality i had
how like uh
like does your mom go to a lot of the
shows she goes to everything bro
she's pulling up yeah she pulling up
tripping to tripping
tripping like novo security at my mom
like they got like a briefing before i
perform like uh kayla's mom's gonna be
here did you have the roof real chain
yeah she'd be rocking my other one she
she vibed out
i love it that's what i want i gotta get
her a big one though like i gotta get
her a solid one for her that's big man
yeah she'd be wearing mine
uh you obviously you're a big football
guy you know you got a lot of friends in
the league um
is your team the rams
um
i like the teams at my homies
[Music]
i got homies on the ramps but right now
i'm going with the seahawks my boyfriend
i have this contract here my boy penny
oh okay okay yes yeah richard penny yeah
that's my boy yeah i got homies i played
for the cardinals
well then
yeah listen man i hate the [ __ ]
i [ __ ] hate them who plays for the
cardinals that you know um whitaker okay
okay yeah that's my boy me and his big
brother played together at san diego
state yeah the seahawks have the most
annoying fan base in football yeah it's
the big the 12th man no it's just like
all these pasty white people who look
like macklemore
they're [ __ ] loud enough to bash the
seahawks on here who would be just
bashing her i'm bashing their pasty fans
all right i don't know who's more
annoying seahawks fans are warriors fans
can we do like a segment in here where
we give people a chance to guess like
your ethnicity
it's just white no people already know
this we're talking i'm just [ __ ]
plain old [ __ ] pasty white guy that's
where he was if i was in seattle
man pasty [ __ ] so you only like
arizona because you're from arizona hey
look [ __ ] is on my skin buddy oh he
really has a cardinal tattoo yeah
damn i'm from phoenix so i [ __ ] with you
i don't watch baseball so that's the
only um sport in which i
don't give a [ __ ] about bass i don't
give a [ __ ] about the diamondbacks i
wear the hat but i can also wear like a
la hat not carrot but football and
basketball sons and cardinals were you a
were you a sons fan before they were
good yeah you sure 100 now
i've been watching the sun so as a child
so yes i have [ __ ] jerseys from when
i was a kid okay but i also was a
michael jordan fan as a kid all right
and
the suns have been asked for a very long
time right yeah i mean did you hold them
down or do you don't of course no of
course 100 held them down check the
twitter profile all right but
i needed somebody to root for i was
rooting for the suns to be the worst
possible so we could get the top draft
picks
and we really didn't do [ __ ] with them
because we drafted like [ __ ] josh
jackson who's the homie shout out to him
he knows uh
that's dragon
that is crazy as [ __ ]
dragon bender
marquise chris
[ __ ] this is a political interview
so i also would root because lebron's my
favorite player ever
so you know the sons were never in the
playoffs so i'm [ __ ]
rooting for lebron the last 10 years to
a cleveland fan
whatever team he was on i was [ __ ]
with you cleveland you're a cleveland
fan
i mean [ __ ] so you're a lakers fan
not anymore no
no once he went to the lakers i had to
so what but lebron lakers don't matter
the lakers is this is a whole other
like level of but you like lebron so you
would like the lakers so say you like
the ladies let me give you some
say you like the lakers i don't like the
lakers why can't you say you like i like
the lakers
so
with that being said you like the
clippers no [ __ ] the clippers you know
what's crazy is somehow living here for
like seven years
six years however long i've been here
i've adopted the hatred for the clippers
how i don't know i just i feel it
like when kawhi leonard hold lebron
during free agency yeah i held that i
took that personal remember when he did
that when kawhi was like everybody
thought he was gonna sign with the
lakers and all the free agents got
scooped up
and then he said i'm going to the
clippers with [ __ ]
palmdale paul over there you know i mean
and uh that's crazy
yeah so i i fight the clippers
for sure i [ __ ] with lebron you know
what i'm saying but look i loved going
to and watching the [ __ ] lakers get
eliminated by the suns last year that
was amazing that was amazing oh yeah
that was great
but so you traded on lebron for the suns
no i was always the suns fan but the
suns were sucking so i'm rooting for
who's like but they're like the suns
take precedent over everything in my
life
it's the sun's then it's the cardinals
then it's lebron
you seen hardball
hardball hard knocks no hardball
the movie yeah
which one is that the baseball team the
little kids the green jerseys remind me
of the coach i don't know what that
means you just watch hardball was
counter reeves in that that is keanu
reeves yeah yeah yeah i saw it in
theater when i was a kid i remember
i saw it one time when it came out why
do i why do i remind you of the coach
because he was a gambler and love sports
sports better oh yeah i'm a degenerate
gambler i believe it oh yeah i can see
it in your face
see how i can see the way you talk about
sports
it's horrible by the way yeah no don't
let me have like
i got some homies in the league and i'll
be getting some info so you know i'll be
[ __ ] i'll be having a little one i
can't say that on here and by homies in
the league i mean guys who are close to
people in the league you can't say that
man that is like which league am i
talking about what if i'm talking about
fantasy football leagues
you're [ __ ] crazy
you know i'm a degenerate though i had a
rough yeah i've had some rough times
you gamble on sports i'm not going to
talk about this i'm here with you it's
not illegal you just i mean it's illegal
in california but like you go to [ __ ]
arizona and just cross the border go to
[ __ ]
go to court site you know what i'm
saying get your bets in and go home you
heard him people
you go to vegas and bet on sports
do you play blackjack craps i shoot
crabs crabs i shoot dice i shoot dice
and i play crabs craps is the funnest
yeah game in vegas craps is hard i've
won a lot on craps
you could also lose fast i've lost a lot
on craps i've lost so bad to the point
where i've got to vegas and went home
the same day oh
you know it's crazy because you're
always thinking like the run's got to
come around
it's like it's going to change i feel it
and then you start buying all the
[ __ ] numbers everything across ben
big i'm going crazy in the field trying
to double
getting sixes all day
i was i always buy it at six i always i
always buy the six and the eight like
heavy is six and eight and then it's uh
i feel like if you try to make it like a
formula you lose yeah it's fair you just
gotta just
feel it a little bit
i really just like watch what's going on
with the shooters like
i'll just watch how everybody's shooting
like you know i'm saying if he keeps
hitting
field numbers i'm gonna bet the field on
this guy if she comes and rows i try to
go to the table that looks like
everyone's just having a terrible day
because i'm like it only get better from
here right no these guys have been
probably gambling
that's the problem i go where the
energy's high and everything is going up
if i [ __ ] yo run up [ __ ] you i don't
care i'm gonna make me some money
craps guy yeah i like that but i like to
shoot dice like
so because i've never actually shot dice
like you know in the [ __ ] room with
the homies so is it is it similar to it
on the pool table majority is it similar
to craps where everyone's just trying to
hit a number
basically okay kind of so it's like you
know
your
point i mean like if you hit 7 or 11 on
the first one you win like automatically
okay you know what i'm saying if you hit
snake or you hit a three or you hit a 12
you lose you crap you lose your money
but you could stay who gets your money
your home whoever you whoever catching
your fate that's whoever got your head
okay okay okay yeah
that makes sense it's the same [ __ ] just
bring some money i'll show you
i got some money we could come shoot
dice one day it's coming out listen i'm
all about gambling man i'm all about
giving my money away literally my entire
life you might win because i'm trying to
hustle you
it's like you got bad luck
what does that mean you're trying to
hustle me what do you what do you think
it means
you're gonna like
play
how do you play bad on purpose
no like i'm gonna play really good
it's just like how can you say you're
going to play really good it's dice
what do you got [ __ ] fake dice no man
i mean just take me with you to a dice
game it's like say saying someone says
i'm going to play really good at
roulette today it's like yeah the
[ __ ] ball is going to bounce where it
bounces it's not the same it's like you
know like you got to have dice
confidence that doesn't that's not a
thing that's space that's not real i
made it up yeah it's not it's definitely
not real i made up all i made up
unless you got some [ __ ] magnetic
dice you got you [ __ ] i made it up
man
dice confidence nice confidence every
time i have diced coffee how many words
are made
you know how many words are made up in
the dictionary a lot exactly every time
i have confidence i [ __ ] crap out
because i'm like yeah let me buy
maybe you don't need to use your dice
confidence maybe your dice confidence is
you not being confident yeah maybe i
need to stop gambling
i would i would never stop gambling
that's good hey guys listen life advice
never stop gambling man never throw the
dice man play craps
don't bet on the seahawks because uh
drew lock is their starting quarterback
and they're [ __ ] uh but at least dk
metcalf got paid and his friends are
doing this contract here
uh the new album i think if the seahawks
beat the cardinals you wear a seahawks
jersey that's never gonna happen
what if they don't
then what no but what if they don't what
is what's in it for me what do you you
pick your wager man your friends play
for the cardinals so there's nothing
there you'd wear a cardinals jersey
happily you're a man with no team yeah
you're a [ __ ] you're a mercenary
where sharp penny gets [ __ ] traded
tomorrow you're putting a bengals jersey
on go bengals yeah yeah got homies i
played for new york too i'm going for
the giants in new york too the giants
yeah damn for the giants this year i
played for the giants for a day you
played for them for one day yeah i
played for the giants for like five
minutes what happened i got the practice
just at the facility for like five
minutes all right nobody else was
practicing did you get paid no
oh no i saw
i didn't know if you had like a no i
just wanted to go visit the homies oh
yeah everybody said i saw you i was like
i was like were you on the practice
school i wanted to go visit the homies
that probably like damn full you must
have been cheeks if they were like after
five minutes after five cutting i'm
actually pretty good i'm just out of
shape i smoke a lot of wheat smoke a lot
of weed don't eat right don't work out
don't work out as much as well as i
could but i do work out pescatarian-ish
chicken-ish i eat chicken chicken is
good
you know what i'm saying what would you
say to someone who's a vegetarian
stop being a [ __ ] what else
no
it's just their choice you know what i'm
saying just making sure there's so many
good like you know i'm saying
alternatives like have you ever had
cauliflower of course it's great i'm on
keto it's great have you um have you
i've had like a mushroom that tastes
like catfish
it was amazing
i'd be sus a very uh
suspect of that it was amazing
it was amazing
it was like soul food vegan food
it's great i had a vegan mac and cheese
once it was god-awful it was god-awful
yeah you didn't go to the right place i
don't want to go i don't want to go to
the right place it's okay it was a money
man album release party and he's vegan
yeah so they had all vegan options and i
didn't know so i'm just like maybe it
was just since it was like a mass thing
it wasn't as good but like my vegan the
me the vegan macaroni and cheese that
i've had was really well
but you would obviously prefer to eat
the breakfast i mean i eat regular
macaroni and cheese yeah like i'm um i'm
not gonna never give up cheese i'm a
cheese guy you gotta eat the cheese man
cheese is good i love the swine that's
why maybe i'm i just love me some sweets
give it up for like a week but why
don't have a reason i love bacon have
you ever had turkey bacon i've had
turkey bacon it's not it's [ __ ]
terrible it's it's really good for me
it's just the worst [ __ ] ever imagine
having bacon
and then being like
let me try this turkey bacon
it's like
it's like
jacking off first real sex
i'm gonna jack off
me too first anyway
why
i just that's just me bro what's the
go-to uh category
i just i'm a scroller like me too if i
see something i like
tabs
i'll just go to i go to new i like that
preview i go to new though i like
everything i don't like to go watch [ __ ]
that i watched already
so you log in to pornhub so your
history's there i'll pay for porn
you pay for porn i've paid for porn only
fans are like a sight only fans but like
i'll go like red to premium
oh you're a real one yeah jesus christ
like look what i'll be singing about all
day who's on the uh
mount rushmore of porn stars for you
oh man um
i don't really have one i don't really
get into the names all mine are old yeah
the bang bros era yeah
oh is that like i did an interview with
um
alexis texas see i'm not into white
women so i know obviously respect to her
she's a legend but not for me
alexis texas is puerto rican she looks
white as a [ __ ] she's not she's not full
puerto rican
i don't think she's puerto rican i don't
know about that i've met her i don't
know she doesn't seem puerto rican to me
she might be like 10 the same way he's
jewish she's puerto rican yeah i have a
white uncle
i have two white uncles yeah uncle dan
and uncle jeff but i'm i identify as a
black man i gotta go
do you know who isla fox is no
isil fox
she's a og yeah i'm gonna look her up
i'm gonna look her up
mia khalifa is cool
that's a [ __ ] low-hanging fruit
answer
tell me you don't watch porn she's like
mia khalifa she's always there
i mean i guess she retired she don't
even have that many
she's always there like you know i'm
saying i don't know anybody else's like
names like i'm not really oh i
understand you know i'm not getting that
deep into porn i respect it you know
what i'm saying i'm ella anderson she's
up there i don't know who that is
yeah i don't know what it is you just
you know you know you're not invested
but you you you you'll uh see there you
go you're trying to porn chain me and
this is like you watch way more
important than i do i don't know what
that means all right um
what what is uh you know what is the
factors in which you uh subscribe or not
subscribe to the only fans page
um
you got to be like
like it got to be all the way out there
like i'm not taking a chance
so if you subscribe and then and it's
like feet pics and [ __ ] i'm not [ __ ]
with that like i'm gonna unsubscribe
report
you'll report the page yeah yeah report
what if you subscribe and then
it's like
uh don't they sell messages
i don't know
that's way too far yeah yeah no that's
crazy would you ever start and only fans
if this rap [ __ ] ended up not working
out and put porn on there no let's say
20 years from now no no no
um
no i respect that i have a degree i can
do a lot of other stuff you know ddg's
not only fans but he gives a game like
instead of like giving like i wouldn't
put porn on there right but you you
might go on there and give like life
advice i have only fans now for that for
stuff like that you haven't only fancy
yes currently yeah it's just i don't use
it though is it active no no it's
inactive how many posts did you get in
before you decided i'm out two
two yeah so how much money did you make
of those two posts i think i made like
65 bucks some [ __ ] like that
i'm bad yeah i didn't know i never went
public
65
go subscribe to uh well first of all get
the album shout out for that 65 yeah i'm
out right now yeah there was nothing on
there by the time this comes out the
album will be out uh and
go subscribe to his only fans yeah but
see can i have to tell the story about
the only fans now you can't just let me
just oh yeah
i was gonna put unreleased music on only
fans but that's a great idea that was
like stealing so i couldn't do that so
that was the reason why i had an only
fantastic product nation have a problem
with this i didn't think that would be
something that i should do and i didn't
even want to take it there so i just sat
back once i got like that could be like
detrimental how do you like rock nation
i don't think you should ask me these
type of questions okay okay
what's wrong
i'm just asking shout out to jay-z like
do you get oh [ __ ] i [ __ ] love rock
nation oh it's a great place right
how's the broad buffalo how's the brunch
no we didn't have a brunch this year but
how is it like i've never been to a
brunch you've never been in the right
place
i'm a pandemic baby
like so everything like i get like
i haven't experienced the 100
roc nation feel
you know what i mean because a lot of
the stuff hasn't been going on have you
ever talked to jay-z hello that's my
[ __ ] i'll call him right now it's
amazing hell yeah you'll call him right
now i'll call him right now call him he
might not answer
well say ruchi answer you gotta save
your calls
he's like listen i i i could call him
but he's gotta count i mean i met jay-z
a couple of times like really hung out
with him i hung out with him once nice
it was mad cool yeah yeah yeah i'm
saying
emery introduced me to him like super
yeah shout out to emery emery's that's
my dog that's my og
uh do you get like i heard you get like
a discount code for the clothes can i
use yours um i could just bring you some
stuff okay you gotta like that you go to
the factory bring some [ __ ]
some of that paper planes
i'm not going to say that i don't hear
because i don't know how everybody else
got it yeah okay that's fair you got it
i heard i heard in the roc nation
wheelhouse you're pretty high up in the
you know
uh
total streams a month
i just like to just pop up over there
and do my thing man you know i don't
know i heard you're doing more than
doing your thing i heard you're doing
your [ __ ] thing you know i'm sorry oh
man i just you know i just i appreciate
people that appreciate me man you know
you know as the rock nation loves me i
just try to love them back hey as best
as i can man you know i love it man
shout out to right now
i can't stand you shout out to rock
nation man you know what i'm saying
[ __ ] ho jiggle my [ __ ]
let's go throw up the diamond you know
what i'm saying there it is this thing i
swear i'm illuminated after this go
stream the project two two two out right
now
by the time this comes out yes two two
two will be our witness comes out go get
it you know what i'm saying more videos
coming more videos coming you know what
i'm saying video coming probably a week
after a week after release
um
would you do a collab project with
anybody
um because i feel like you know blas and
beno have two classics you know i feel
like you you you might do a little
if anybody would want to do a collab
tape with me i want it you know what i'm
saying if it makes sense we'll both do
it but i don't like i'm not yearning to
do anything
yeah i think you said yearning yeah like
i'm not like okay okay is that not the
right word to use i don't know you said
it right i just uh i don't know it
sounded a little distorted
there it is i'm not hearing it i swear i
say it you did you did i kind of beat
boxed it up shout out to caleb uh go get
the project and go support man shout out
to bootleg kid for totally roasting me
in every interview man
[Laughter]